[Music]
10 million michiganders will be informed
on october 2nd 2020.
the life form that controls the state
whitmer net sent two computers back
through time their mission
destroy the records of the nursing home
death rate and to watch michigan seniors
die a slow
painful death the first computer was
programmed to erase all records of the
nursing home death rate
it failed the second was sent to stop an
event as before
the free speech resistance was able to
send a lone warrior
an entertainer to uncover the numbers a
protector
it was just a question of which one
would arrive first
[Music]
come with me if you want to learn
[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
you're not my half asian lawyer bill
richmond that's true uh audio weight is
here
gerald a is here quarter black hey good
morning we have a lot to be talking
about today we're talking about voter
fraud we'll be talking about amy coney
barrett we'll be talking about the
supreme court and john oliver and why is
a limey prick
let's say johnny boy who works with us
he was chewing gum when we were doing
brazilian jiu jitsu
really yeah were you there i was like
teaching a strangle
[Laughter]
it does make it easier if he chokes
himself out i'm gonna go in here
are you trying gum it's just [ __ ] it out
was it a problem
yes it's a problem you [ __ ] we're
breathing on each other
fresh breath by the way uh please do uh
consider following me on instagram
because apparently that's where
lifestyle stuff happens outside of
the youtube uh you're a thought and uh
do you consider joining up my club at
lateralcutter.com
slash mug club that's the only reason
any of this works to begin with and
we'll be taking your chat afterwards my
question to you
is do you feel like you have a handle on
the voter fraud going on
uh and how do you think they're going to
try and block amy coney barrett
um i'm surprised they haven't just
trotted out a cartoon of her with a
bishop hat at this point
what well just the whole
anti-catholicism the whole
it has to be subtle like we didn't mean
all catholics just you know all
catholics
democrats and subtle that does not go no
i know if you look at
just how they try and disqualify amy
coney barrett for the court
that means that no woman could ever be
in the supreme court oh okay
yeah yeah this came from i think we'll
get to it new york times like i just
don't understand how you could be a
supreme court justice and a loving mom
oh so oh that argument yeah okay
so they really are baron spinster and
they all want they want to demo
you know demonize all catholics who are
not barred from the
communion right yeah that's the only
thing that's like having a bad nra
rating it's like a badge of honor i
couldn't take communion right
right i don't think pelosi knows yet i
don't think she understands
she just won't walk up she just isn't
she can't see through her hutu tribesman
scarf
she's left kneeling i want to use the
word pandering uh
harlot but you know yeah not a fan
uh but before let's see what they're
talking about on cnn really quickly
wisconsin sets new
coronavirus case record this weekend oh
well guess what that's
every day that's true because there are
more coronavirus cases today
than yesterday and there will likely be
more tomorrow unless there are no
new cases you don't need to count from
sesame street to do that none
no new cases if there's one more it's a
new record
that's that's the problem that's right
yeah counting it past flu season
and going into the next season by the
way doesn't have the number what were
the flu deaths this last season
2019 2010 do we have those numbers
i think zero i don't we conquered the
flu um speaking of pandemics though
uh we know that it hasn't been handled
perfectly sure by our
commander-in-chief by president donald
trump so there's always the alternative
if you feel more confident
uh in this week in biden
understanding what you may hear about me
i have incredibly good judgment
one i married jill and two
i appointed johnson to the academy i
just want you to know that
just clap for that you stupid backers
that's why i made it a priority
my entire career to work closely with
you from the time i
got to the senate 180 years ago
you know
oh that was a great segment you stupid
bastards
cheer for me you dumb pricks yeah you
lavish me with praise you
filthy [ __ ] i was appointed by martin
van buren you should respect me
all you barren [ __ ] who are unable to
bear
children give me praise honor me
you dumb [ __ ]
yeah no it means i'm buddies yeah that's
like the kid who took that
way too seriously hey i heard your mom
was so
fat that uh whatever i don't know what
was that she plays pool with the planet
kid's like yeah i hear your mom
uh had breast cancer and had a
mastectomy like oh my god oh
geez it was way too far and he's like
well you know what you started it no he
didn't start that
you made this point but i'm very much
looking forward to the atlantic's full
piece
yeah dumbbells do i think it was a joke
sure but i think we should take it at
face value just like they do with donald
trump with the losers and suckers which
when i mean face value i mean anonymous
sources as opposed to videotaping of
course
you got to play the game like they say
you know there is more proof
that joseph biden said dumb bastards
yeah stupid
stupid bastards that's way worse because
i know little kids were like he said the
s word i'm like your brother said [ __ ]
they're like no
no that's not even that bad he said
stupid bastards
there's more evidence of that than
donald trump saying losers and suckers
and by the way
i don't really care hey i want to be
clear about this do i support our troops
absolutely do i support our military
of course do i believe in a strong
military defense yes do i think that you
can support our military without
necessarily supporting every single war
absolutely do i think there are some
stupid bastards in the military well the
sort of the odds would say at least but
he didn't know that
absolutely 180 years in the senate i
don't even know if that's
this is the thing if you cannot tell
that was a float then that's a problem
maybe he could have been joking there
but it was bad so he needed like a
warm-up act for the troops like they
weren't there was a very cold reception
he was getting
bad jokes he was like see i married jill
crickets right
yeah exactly we don't care he's into the
ropes right
you don't just bring out apollo and jeff
ross right on the outside
exactly you need a rich little to sort
of till the soil a little bit
have him do his reagan yeah he got a
fantastic reagan
also what it would look like if robert
de niro were
like cooking vegetables it might look
something like this
the impressions okay uh anyway
um hey i don't know i know you're not
audio weight is not on audio
sounds it just me it could just be me it
sounds a little bit roomy
this is what happened around joseph
let's move on to the voter fraud issue
this is something that
okay let me be really clear when people
say hey there's no evidence
of uh voter fraud at all there's no
evidence of mass voter fraud
those people are either completely
uninformed or lying
now there are two issues here as to
mail-in voting
and i think that democrats are real and
i want you guys to to be
clear on this because i think that
republicans and conservatives have done
a disservice by conflating the issues
and then of course democrats just try
and act like it doesn't exist at all
except for the fact that you might look
at black uh
black liberal groups and organizations
and biden himself voting in person
because they realize oh crap
mail in voting doesn't work and the
majority of them are going to be
democrats we're kind of shooting
ourselves in the deck yeah
you're like why would he say dick i
don't know if he's joking around it's
buying you can never tell
um but there are two sides of this issue
there's there's uh voter fraud
okay and i want to be clear what we will
be talking about today i've only uh
used examples that have been verified by
a judge an official court
or the state uh governing body for the
election or an unbiased commission so
there are hundreds of examples that you
can find that are not included here
but these are ones that uh that wouldn't
be in dispute
two sides you wouldn't think there's
voter fraud yeah right happens outright
fraud
and then a bigger side of the issue but
is separate is the fact that we have a
mail-in system that is just not
functional is just not equipped or
designed to deal with an election of
this scale those are two sides of the
issue
the voter fraud side of the issue uh
occurs to the tune of as you'll see
thousands of verified votes which is the
margin of error more so
yeah in swing states 500 something in
florida with the bush gore election
and then the the processing issues uh
number in the hundreds of thousands to
millions
undeniable completely verifiable we'll
walk you through it anyone who says
otherwise is either misinformed that's
most likely
or lying or brian stelter so that's the
third case send him this link
he won't read it before we get to the
empirical sir
this gum is really gonna oh that is
fossilized wow
that's gonna mess up the finish it is
used um let's start with the anecdotal
so this happened this morning i haven't
been able to verify this but project
veritas had a new video on voter fraud
occurring
again
[Laughter]
video you can see the video there was a
video out and about
that he has the ballads in his car right
and talking about the only way you can
win is with
money i was looking at them and they
were not filled they were blank
who is the one filling out the absentee
ballots
people who work with like omar
no i know on the surface that would look
pretty bad sure beneath the surface
it's horrible yeah it gets worse
ugly is skin deep and deeper actually
it's like a far infrared beam that goes
below the epidermis
which should be enough now that being
said this is obviously a lot of these
were like somali retirees so i don't
know that it really was affecting the
outcome of the vote
i mean maybe the foregone conclusion i
am the captain now i can't write in
english you feel invalid for me
all right fine who's that
me are you sure you don't want to vote
for ilan no more no
okay all right i'm going to take these
from you i'll take these off your hands
and uh can you let me know where the uh
veterans uh
hospital is i'd like to throw theirs in
a ditch
so um we'll get to that in a second that
actually
happened right that's fine um and uh
over the weekend of course uh
oh no let me show you this too this is
anecdotal yeah this happened with a
friend of mine so i want to be clear a
friend of mine received these ballots
and all a personal identification has
been removed here you can bring this
overlay up there uh token
ballots uh sorry a voter registration
card for his dad
who uh not only hasn't lived at that
house but hasn't been alive for several
decades oh oh okay
it won't be uh it won't be accepted
actually yeah he could just put in a
signature
that looks like his dad's signature and
there could be voting twice which has
happened again to the tune of thousands
where you look at georgia pennsylvania
so
this is something happened with my and i
expect i i
i've received some some mail for the
previous resident at my house
that at the very least was a gross
violation of privacy or i could have
screwed with their lives but
i don't know if i've gotten any voter
cards yet but i'll check with my wife
because she checks the mail because one
time i found a
spider
nightmares are made of so my wife checks
the mail
she doesn't mind spiders if we go into a
scenario where i where we know there
will be snakes i handle it
all right that situation is not a reason
okay so you traded snakes and spiders
snakes and spiders all right that's fine
yeah you're pansy
it's here wow it's called an equitable
arrangement
mr mom it's true and that film does not
hold up
no it doesn't um okay so let's do and
then
they're talking about taxes on cnn
donald trump which we'll get to in a
little bit but let's continue talking
about the voter fraud because
i know i mentioned that people who tell
you there is no evidence of mass
voter fraud or errors i want to include
both of those are uh misinformed or
lying
and uh with our favorite straight uh cnn
hosted in chief
let's take your guess here is mr stelter
americans are not hearing trump lie
about voter fraud every day
but his biggest supporters are they are
hearing it
all the time and he's been telling ghost
stories about voter fraud all year long
he has used the word rigged dozens of
times
the word ballots hundreds of times he
did it again just
one hour ago son of a [ __ ]
how could he he's using the word ballots
of guys listen we have a president with
no respect for american cultural in do
you
want a commander-in-chief who says the
word
ballot it's an election year of course
he's going to use the word
and he did it one hour oh my gosh
he used the word vote 4 452
times and then black people should be
free to vote unhindered
oh gosh that's actually good more
nuisance money
my god with the nuisance money
sweetheart if you're watching my wife
make sure i don't pay painting my actual
woman watching okay let's go through a
couple of things here uh
there's a big difference between
absentee and what we're talking about
with me this
year this election there will be 44.2
million people who get unsolicited
ballots people meaning people who will
get
uh ballots who did not request them that
is very different
from absentee ballots in most states and
it varies from state to state but this
is now a blanket rule and of course you
have different states now who are
extending the deadlines past the
elections for the processing
my solution is really simple at this
point hey all right you want to do meal
involving fine
if it can't be counted and processed by
election we're done that's it yeah you
have time now
yeah just do it just guys you should
know if you are too incompetent
to fill out a return envelope that is
already basically i think it's
pre-stamped if i'm not mistaken
i have no idea well i don't know the
last time i bought a stamp was it a
furniture store i think you have to
stamp them
and from what i understand the it has to
be postmarked by midnight on election
day
that's in most states that's an insane
system because it's just going to wait a
very
long election stream right for us it's
like two and a half weeks long
no interest in doing that can we get a
live camera on the stamper right there
yeah we'll give you almost the results
44.2 million now let's go two states
here examples of
of active fraud okay that has occurred
and then we'll get to the air so active
let's go to pennsylvan the wonderful
state of pennsylvania swing state uh a
male sort of this is the one you've
heard about recently through
trump ballots in the trash there were
nine military ballots that were found
they were just discarded in pennsylvania
seven of them were for trump two were
unknown
this is just what we found do you have
any idea how easy it would be to do that
even
how incompetent the postal service is
they've posted losses
for 13 years you're complaining about
donald trump writing off losses as a
business owner
your taxpayers fund a business
that would do better if they didn't use
the wheel
they set out several logs and just roll
the trucks right yeah yeah egyptian
system
just use email there's just some guy
with a beard and rapids with a log
santa claus i'd pay to see that all
right uh
texas let's go to the wonderful state of
texas that the polls are now saying
toss-up statement in case you wondered
if the polls were designed to manipulate
public opinion rather than reflect them
texas attorney general there has brought
134 felony charges
134 over widespread that's not why
i'd hate to make a claim that would
force me to pay nuisance money
georgia the good old state of georgia
some would say significant in the
election
yeah the secretary of state brad i want
to make sure i'm not getting this right
wrong brad raffen's burger
point you go with the hollywood name
just like brad cruz
[Laughter]
brad steele pick the first street you
lived on
uh a thousand residents
voted twice in the state's june ninth
prime minister oh hundreds
of a thousand some residents literally
vote often that's a lot no examples
new jersey this one i love a judge even
ruled and ordered a new election because
a sitting city councilman was charged
with fraud
over 800 ballots could not be counted
because there was active fraud from
someone who was already
in government which is always remarkable
to me by the way when people talk you
think about the rock against bush you
think about the
the rage against the machine but all of
a sudden these people rage against the
machine their rebels
are encouraging male encouraging
trusting the government
already elected officials and a giant
government bureaucracy in the postal
service
with your vote is there anything less
rebellious than
rocking the mail-in vote for pelosi
think about that for a second well you
know what maybe voting for joseph biden
ah yeah we're going to destroy the
system by voting for the guy who has
done
nothing but work in the system for 50
years has hair plugs
and doesn't know where he is half the
time 180 years
from the source see my shirt for
reference
by the way hit the notification bell if
you are watching this because
uh subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
on youtube um
and if you hit the notification you get
notified on your mobile and of course
your
audio podcast is available on spotify
apple and android before we move on to
the
actual like wide spread although i would
think that the menu
the many millions of examples of
widespread voter
uh processing errors it seemed like yeah
yeah exactly so in the two
mit this like far right leaning
institution right yeah yeah mit actually
came out with a study in
about the 2008 election race 3.9 million
ballots that were requested or mailed
out never arrived
2.9 million that's a good reason for the
postal service
yeah exactly uh 2.9 million for whatever
reason were never returned so let's just
say they just decided not to vote but
800
000 people's ballots were invalidated
either for being late
for not being filled out correctly for
not having a signature i think stamps
are an issue sometimes
that is massive if you're talking about
wanting everybody's vote to count
having them do it by mail is the
absolute worst
possible way and we've known this for
decades that's why we don't do it in
mass
some people have done it and they've
worked with private industry for years
and voting to work have it done by fedex
yeah and
and this is why the uh the death rates
and this is why the numbers matter for
coronavirus
because this is all done on the on the
pretense that this is all in response to
some
crazy epidemic that just is killing
everybody who walks out of their house
but it's just not the case and then yeah
that that's why they're trying to push
the uh
mail-in voting thing right it's the
dumbest thing ever you brought it up it
typically it impacts people who are
voting democrat
more than republican like if you're like
hey what is the worst thing
on the e delay because they're gonna
they might be listening like oh
i think it's too eight lay yeah that's
true uh
i don't know it's never too late to
screw with democrats i think it was four
million
people requested or or are getting mail
and vows or said they would vote by mail
i'm not exactly
sure how it works because you don't have
to request them now yeah uh and i was
surprised because a lot of republicans
were getting nervous saying
well 2.4 million i believe are coming
from democrats and 1.6 million from
republicans go
on considering how often republicans
talk about voting in person how
important it is to them i was surprised
that it wasn't 0.0 million
so 1.6 is not that bad and voter
registration is up
in donald trump's key demographics and
down in the ones that are key democrat
uh democrat
demographics and it's interesting that
you see now the pivot we're like you
should you should vote by mail
vote by mail in person is if you can
vote
just in person get out there you know
just do it early
and wear you're mad yeah it's your
patriotic duty to brave the coronavirus
now that's going to be the pivot like
right this is too important to stay home
this is true you got to go out do your
parts it is your duty
i know my duty i've been working and
i've been in the senate for 180 years
but you know i would give him the
benefit of the doubt if he were if he
wasn't crazy
yeah like it's kind of like when an old
person says something absolutely
racist yeah you're like one second i'm
not sure if that was a joke because
they're 95
and it didn't really have a punch line
yeah like i don't know if he was joking
saying he'd been in government in 180
years because there was no
setup punchline he just continued like
nothing had happened and it wasn't funny
and there was there was no intent there
yeah old people say racist things
typically because they're often racist
yeah i think maybe that's the brilliance
of joe biden we just don't know anymore
we can't really tell if he's joking if
the prompter was wrong
if like he just forgot where he was you
know tony clifton of presidential
candidates
that's that's forty
uh all right let's go to the mail and
now this is those were the examples of
outright fraud right okay so i want you
to send this if anyone said there are no
examples well we just listed four or
five now let's go to the mail-in process
not working and it shouldn't be
surprising yeah right
if you understand um that uh the mailing
is run by government
oh let's talk about that although we
hate the police right we want to defund
the police
we believe that unions we believe that
police unions protect bad
cops well let me ask you this can you
what do you think happens to bad postal
workers have you ever tried to fire one
it's not possible they just keep coming
back i had a friend
there's no way you just put them in a
break room forever
until retirement yeah it's like teachers
same thing it's just a
life of nothing but bad gammon and tuna
fish sandwiches
and they get they get it's like it's
almost the uaw level
of non-workers per retiree jeez
all right so the mail in prussia let's
go to california the sunny state of
california more than a hundred thousand
ballots were rejected in an election
now uh recently i think this was last
election or a primary i don't have the
exact year in front of me
um and here's the thing yeah i want to
be clear most of them were because
people missed the deadline but that's
not an issue here because
we don't know if there's a deadline no
it depends on well it depends when the
cutoff
depends how the votes are coming in in
which county so in michigan
the deadline is going to be once wayne
county detroit comes in and we don't
no more western michigan or northern
michigan with california one san
francisco
that's the only deadline we care about
then cut it off yeah what about temecula
i don't give a [ __ ] about temecula
it's san francisco is the deadline folks
so
a lot of them missed the deadline but 27
000 in california were rejected because
the signatures didn't match the voter or
just didn't have any signature at all
yeah
think about that didn't match the voter
but nobody's doing it i mean has anyone
here ever forged their own like
like sick notes from their parents or
doctors when you were a kid and you're
at school
i don't know they're gonna do oppo
research on me and like claim that's a
felony
yeah it's on his permanent record signed
myself an absentee slip
as my dad or dr grombois it's not i mean
you know it's i didn't shoot it
i didn't beat up a cop right that was
a car with a dead body already in it all
right new york
six weeks after the election this recent
one uh that two congressional seats they
still hadn't been decided
so that's an interesting one there could
be 250
000 voters in new york uh who could just
be illegal or using false social
security numbers because law that they
voted to get a driver's license where
you can use foreign documentation
foreign documentation for a driver's
license you remember this when i went to
the dmv here
i had two pieces of picture id yeah um
my birth certificate but they used to
tell you tear up your social security
number so i brought in my tax returns
right
and they said well we can't accept it i
said that's your tax id number i said
it's
you called it that you called it the
claim number
just put it in the machine there that
says social security number and put in
the number that has the exact same
amount of numbers as a social security
number like don't you have the ability
to just
pop in my social security number and see
if it's me
and they said we can't do that here at
the dmv would you like us to handle your
elections
[Applause]
check the box if you're satisfied i'd
have someone who worked here
go and bring me uh my wife managed to
find my social security number i think
it was hidden in a gun
safe yeah well what about this what if
we had what 250 000 what if we said 250
000 russians are going to be able to
vote in new york are you guys cool with
that
i mean you think russia you think the
election interference sparked 250 000
votes for donald trump
let's just say that across the nation
carry that out into texas and california
we know texas is somewhere just under a
hundred thousand right in california
there are claims of 400 000
roughly right i can't substantiate it
because it's just a claim a 400
000 people that have the ability to vote
that are not residents of the united
states yeah period and again the the
margin of victory in florida was what
537
for for bush over gore yeah and i think
this decided the election or at least it
was a huge part of it i think in some of
the swing states too it's a very close
margin of victory i think it was like 80
000 combined votes
that he won by in a couple of swing
states that basically determined the
election so where where's the line for
mass they're like oh there's no
widespread voter fraud where where's
your line
yeah what does it take millions i draw
the line you know
intent matters here yeah so i draw the
line intentionally
five uh but now that we have over five
hundred thousand
different uh intentions sort of goes out
the window
incompetence takes over which is you
know
also the same reason i have a problem
with joe biden becoming president i want
to be clear there's content and there's
incompetence there's intent
voter fraud we have those examples and
then there's incompetence which is
pretty much any
many government agencies yeah well what
about just throwing them away just
that guy you talked about it seven of
those votes that's only seven and jake
tapper and cnn came on and said this was
clearly a a mistake an administrative
mistake
how a person that was hired threw them
in the trash
how is that a glitch in the system like
what the hell kind of argument is that
somebody knowingly
through votes heroin
vomit sock yes are you serious loud
it's just not an administrative mistake
okay
it's just some homeless guy who has no
arms or legs on a skateboard with his
nubs who's using it to blow his nose
that's how we found it he's like can you
blow my nose i can't reach i'm like
these are ballots really yeah i've used
them before they work great wow
absorbent i love the paperwork hello
the numbers really matter and we are
going to be of course in michigan uh
on october 2nd that's friday at noon the
rally in lansing
uh for the uh the senior death toll we
are going to be
talking uh about the policy proactively
that has led to the deaths of many many
seniors in michigan and how you've been
misled and we have some exclusive
information that we're still waiting on
right now but it takes a while because
freedom of information requests from the
government
uh sometimes they take a long time also
when you have a little authoritarian
governor who doesn't think she has to
honor those uh
requests during a pandemic well then she
just doesn't
oh yeah you know how it is yeah that's
not a good thing
then we also have a virginia sorry final
state here uh a thousand some voters
received two
mail-in ballots no i don't know if they
actually voted twice like the other ones
that we can
just they received they could have so
yeah i guess it's as good as mine
but we have a problem with donald trump
joking about vote twice to see we don't
have a problem with a thousand people
actually being able to vote twice so if
you were to measure
um the sort of the price tag on a vote
okay let's say this is a little mental
exercise yeah and you know what
bloomberg did put a price tag on he did
it's the felony fines
i don't know what i don't know what the
average is but i assume it's a few
hundred dollars um
if you were to put a price tag would you
say it's more than ten thousand dollars
over three thousand ads which is the
entirety of the russian
the russian interference past elections
yeah exactly we're not even getting the
billions of dollars in manipulated
search results from big tech google
alphabet youtube twitter facebook
just okay how many how many votes
what is a vote worth how much how much
do you think if they would never be
caught how much do you think a
politician would pay for a vote to
guarantee them an election
particularly in a swing state like
pennsylvania
what three dollars yeah because if it's
three dollars if it's four dollars if
it's ten dollars
it's more than all of putin's minions
combined
from the kgb running clickbait ads on
facebook
so i just want to be clear when we talk
about interference in our election
this is the problem the same problem we
have with the media is not the lies that
you see proactively but the lies by
omission that's why i don't have a
problem with maddow people say well why
do you why do you talk about men why
don't you talk about matter i don't care
about matter listen
you know you know what you're getting
from an msnbc lesbian who looks like a
12 year old boy you know exactly what
you're getting
i don't say listen she goes and gets the
princeton does it to the barbershop she
goes and says give me the princeton that
used to be the number three so my point
is you know what you're getting
when you have brian stelter who every
day goes out there
every time he does a show it's once a
week because work ethic so he goes out
and he says this is the importance of
the media when you have donald trump
trashing the media
yeah listen the only institution that
americans trust
less than they did for you is the media
and rightfully so
rightfully so you've said that none of
these examples exist
yeah and you call donald trump a liar
every time he brings up the fact that
this could lead
to widespread voter fraud if you want
your vote counted don't do like every
single time you're like
there's no evidence of this sir every
time he just goes and lies and he said
ballots again
he said it he said balance like his word
of the day yeah
well he only has time for one show a
week because the rest of the week he's
having
straight sex with his female wife also i
shouldn't say this on air but i have
many [ __ ] on the side
sorry sweetie you had to find out that
way i have a voracious
straight sex appetite female
you go to therapy oh my gosh
[Laughter]
the only thing that gets me more excited
than another woman is maybe kangaroo
because they have three vaginas oh bob
three is better three is better than
none
i don't understand this wait do they
actually dave landau was telling me
about that
i didn't watch that episode no idea i
cannot verify this all the other sources
dave all the other sources that i
provided for you i can i'll vouch for
i don't know i don't know about the
kangaroos
or to be honest uh mr stelter's daily
sexual
you're right she have no speculation
but really quickly i do want to let you
guys know don't be doing the michigan
stream but we are doing of course the
live debate stream
tomorrow night tuesday i believe when
does it start there uh token do we know
it starts at 8 30 eastern when is 8 30
eastern
8 30 eastern and we're actually going to
have ted cruz on the stream
wow uh interview with our predictions
senator ted cruz looking forward to that
and uh as well i need to talk about our
wonderful sponsor uh even brendan come
in here and model for black rifle coffee
delicious coffee i had some this morning
you can go to
blackriflecoffee.comcrowder you get 20
off your first order model
how do you like which one's your
favorite there even brendan uh
probably silence or smooth yeah why what
do you like about it
get out of here do you like how smooth
it is uh he has no idea silence
about silence i can tell that person is
not caffeinated
morgan's shot um and we do have an
interview by the way
uh coming up i believe next week i just
want to let you know because his
kickstarter that's right
obviously the author and creator of
earthworm jimmy that's right
graphic novel out so that's the big bill
over there that's the first one yeah
yeah this is bigfoot bill yes his most
recent one but yeah earthworm gym two
has
three days three days left on the
campaign on the campaign kickstarter so
we had to
pre-tap an interview with him because of
the travel to michigan but we couldn't
get it up before his kickstarter it was
finished we are going to get to john
oliver here now
and uh some of his do we have two
abcb comments uh how'd you love that
people
before you got i don't know if we said
that uh if you go to blackrockcoffee.com
slash crowd or twenty percent off the
first order
that was the first thing i am the worst
that was uh i mean
it doesn't hurt it's one of those things
if you drink coffee just drink the
better coffee it's fresh roasted it's
better than the coffee you're drinking
you what you're you're chock full of
crap
your maxwell poop yeah yeah
yeah i'm sorry i interrupted it's better
than that it's chalk
this is this you know chock-full of nuts
wishes they could be chock-full of black
rifled coffee oh they're
full of coffee no but it's better and
it's better
a lot of you don't care if it's owned
operated with pro pro some profits going
to uh veterans uh causes it's just
better coffee let's just say that's the
only
it's better coffee sometimes people say
why do you have limited sponsorships
because most sponsors suck
do you have an idea how many supplement
companies reach out to me like will you
advertise this my well let me see is it
uh is it
nsf certified like do i know that what's
in there is it like well we don't want
to pay for that well i don't want you to
pay on my show
oh why not no all right we'll go find
some
ass model on instagram
they're cheap yeah they are cheap
they're everywhere
worth every penny okay so john oliver
right now is
i don't want to say making the rounds
it's tough for me to debunk john oliver
like we used to
rebuttals because the arguments are
really yeah yeah um
there's not a lot of there actually
before we get to john oliver you wanted
to talk about donald trump
yeah so i don't i don't let me know i
don't give a rat's ass about this
because
it was like uh like uh haralda rivera
opening capone's too
for sure oh oh my gosh you mean a
business owner
lost money what a freaking
nightmare i know well i i just i hate
that it's going around like it's some
bombshell story i'm like you guys
have really lost all perspective on what
a bombshell story is
just quickly people also not bombshell
stories are when actual
bombshells go off exactly that's that's
not the same
how much how much capital did most
people risk last year when they got it
well
let's be clear about this because people
are making the argument they're saying
that oh donald trump paid less in taxes
i saw this tweet donald trump paid less
in taxes than some kid working at
mcdonald's for 40 hours away
how much did that kid invest in r d yeah
exactly well it was it was in 2016 that
hillary clinton said
donald trump doesn't want you to see
your tax returns because that'll show
that it hasn't paid anything in tax
and then he's like well that makes me
smart right so yeah yeah
so it's a breaking news story that
somebody paid the legal amount of taxes
that they owed right they use the tax
system that is there and also by the way
i don't know if you guys know this but
joe biden uses the exact same scheme he
has an s
corp that basically prevents him from
having to pay medicare and social
security
and saves him five hundred thousand
dollars
verifiable in a year in a year for the
business profits
the business i always forget that
politicians
also make business on the side there are
no
insider trading laws exactly so i mean
and joe biden actually came out and said
that this was a loophole and
it should be closed and it's like oh by
the way and i'm using it until it is
right like why is somebody going out and
using the tax code an
illegal thing now and it's something
that we should all like everything i
don't want to get into using the tech i
think the task
should be simplified my issues they're
not backing on dumb they're banking on
dumb americans who don't understand what
it is to run a business
idea how many years i made nothing now
there wasn't hundreds of thousands of
dollars that you had to
generate pay that you had to pay out to
create websites to build a studio people
don't understand that yeah some
just revenue coming in doesn't mean net
profit that happens
all the time let me ask you this for
someone who says oh my gosh i can't
believe that a business owner
would pay less than i do how many of you
have ever paid out six or seven figures
to employees annually
okay how many of you have ever had to do
that and if you haven't then you may not
have a firm grasp as to what a business
owner has to do
yeah with their taxes how many years
have you had were you how many years
have you had to borrow money
just to invest in inventory so that you
could maintain the business for the next
quarter do you realize that that's a
huge percentage of american businesses
they have to borrow money just to just
acquire
inventory big risks absolutely and then
you have to pay taxes in most states on
that inventory before it sells can you
imagine that you have to pay taxes on
something you haven't even sold yet
that is just part of stuff that they
take from you and by the way those years
money selling my vote they shouldn't tax
that that should be tax free
man always gets the better and he's
always
well it just it just shows me that
people have no understanding of how the
tax system is designed and it's not
necessarily a bad thing because
i am incentivized to go out and risk my
capital to get a job created that pays
you
well there are a lot of people who don't
the media does they're hoping that you
don't
so they lie about it so it's very clear
it's it's a non-issue for anyone who's
ever run a business or understands
someone who's run a business uh even if
you're for example a career politician
who uses your hot tips to create an
immensely profitable business at the
expense of the taxpayers so
the point is it's been uh who cares um
all right john oliver did a recent video
here uh
our segment i don't know what you call
is it a show anymore at this i don't
think so
are there paid people to laugh at it
does it count
on uh and people have been getting mad
about uh notorious acb shirts i love
themselves i love it
you stole that from notorious rbg
did she coin it it was stupid and stupid
really hold on a second
notorious rbg was the original
[Laughter]
before biggie was biggie oh my gosh
that's like amy schumer getting mad that
someone stole her [ __ ] she stole from
ellen degeneres yeah
how dare you still steal something i
stole oh my gosh i love it i think
anything that pisses democrats off is
really fun for me right now
all right so john oliver has been
responding the nomination from notorious
acb
you know what i'm gonna do i don't even
like the nickname but i like that
and he tried to make these arguments
that there are two situations there are
two factors here that make this
nomination just completely unfair
and this is an example with john oliver
i do think john oliver can be very funny
an example of john oliver saying
things uh that are exactly the things
that i have been saying
only um i guess he doesn't understand
them because he says something i go well
yeah exactly and then he thinks that
makes his case
when if you just let him say that phrase
and didn't let him follow up to
justify his case you would you would
immediately become a conservative
so uh let me give you an example of that
the first he says that this is unfair
and his claim that mitch mcconnell
is determined to confirm judges and he
goes to an example of
this is this is just so you know this is
the most substantial point that i could
find in the video
as to why it would be unfair to nominate
acb
and mcconnell's willingness to go to the
map for judicial appointments was
perhaps
never more obvious than joining the
kavanaugh hearings because
immediately after christine blasey
ford's gut-wrenching testimony
mcconnell apparently had this
conversation with the president
both of them were kind of testing each
other a little bit where are you at on
this you know how strong are you
and mcconnell basically says to the
president you don't worry about me
i'm strong as mule piss that's his quote
i'm strong as a mule piss
in other words he's not going to freeze
he's not going to give up
he's not gonna surrender wow that
is extraordinary because it's easy to
forget that after blasey ford's
testimony
kavanaugh's confirmation felt a lot less
certain
and to react to what she said with don't
worry i'm strong as mule piss
is both horrendous and deeply weird
first off i think it's deeply awesome i
like when a politician speaks straight
from the hip
i like when i don't know what you guys
do
going down to your old debits grill in
the beltway
swamp but here we know a thing or two
about moose piss
[Applause]
strongest like the smell of moose piss
like the streams
it is
something about electrolyte imbalance it
smells very exciting but
also keep in mind he also just said we
felt as though kavanaugh's uh
confirmation was much more
we felt well no that's the point you
were saying after christine blasey ford
we felt and the good thing is we found
out that it was untrue for example many
people felt disgusted
at the idea of kavanaugh being a gang
rapist
which was verifiably false it turned out
it was actual collusion to just try and
have this guy blocked
so his argument there is can you believe
that mcconnell was talking about moose
piss
when this false charade was going on
it's amazing to me
it's extraordinary do you think people
on the left this is my question do you
think they actually think that kavanaugh
is a gang rapist
still of course i think so you think
they believe that i really do i think oh
come on
no i'm serious i think we can't paint
them all with a brush
no no no no but some of them i would say
the people that were against it are
saying no he's still a rapist on the
court i think that's
they keep referring back to him as
though that story is still true like we
didn't find out this was all false
like they just paused on that story it's
remarkable it was it wasn't the bossy
fourth thing that he like grabbed her
and then fell asleep
something i don't remember
this is when it was me too quite little
like me too me too well what happened
with you he ran a train on me
with guys in illuminati masks like how
many
how far can you count well he may have
passed me a drink at some point maybe i
don't know
and and and the only reason oh my god
i'm sort of keeping a diary since the
only reason
why adam died was because he had kept a
diary
like doug for his entire life
and there was enough evidence of the
diary being verified in other instances
from
outside events and accounts who would
have thought that he was
saved by a diary yeah exactly you mean
there wasn't a page in there that says
ran a train on poor unsuspecting woman
tonight
while the fun had some beers after there
wasn't like that intrigue
and you know what typically a serial
killer like a jeffrey i know people say
well some of them have kept diaries
first off i cannot verify that but i
assume they only do it so they can read
back their crime right with that thrill
they weren't like eight
eight smoked salmon today yeah it wasn't
as good as last week
might try a new place tuesday you mean
the same thing i had a guy's face and i
was erect like that's
yeah like whereas it's just riddled with
like
we had a party today i met a cheerleader
if i'm lucky she may let me hold her
hand
yeah and it's like so omitted from all
of this is gang rape yeah
serial gang rapist so i don't know if if
if john oliver believes it but if he
does then he can't trust anything he
says because he can't be bothered hiring
a researcher because kovid takes its
toll on everybody it does it does
and by the way as far as the precedence
the pr you know precedent i think both
would apply in this instance the senate
didn't hold public confirmation hearings
for the first 127 years
this is a very new thing and again the
case could be made
that yeah you know what we thought hey a
public hearing might be until
you falsely accused a man of gang rape
yeah the most yeah it's like oh you get
your privileges taken away now no
no no no no no no you didn't finish your
dinner so you don't get your dessert no
no no
no you don't get any more public
hearings when you fabricate stories of
gang rape right
the most boring straight-laced guy in
the world king rapist
yeah it's like because he likes beer
yeah exactly over shot yeah poor guy
that's how you know it's not true and
like
hey are you a gang rapist no i'm not do
you drink beer on tuesday
i like beer i have a follow-up what does
that mean booker
i have no idea i like beer he was it was
a little vocal on that one
he's like i'm not going to back down
from this i like basically but there is
a silver lining here
many democrats have already said that
they're going to boycott the hearings
and they have no interest in meeting oh
with acb well that's their job your wish
is our command okay
bye you don't need to show up yeah
especially not
an accuser of gang rape
[Applause]
what's your relationship like with
alcohol um and by the way this is
something else another reason that uh
obviously we don't need to
to host these these public hearings
she's already been with bear this isn't
the case with all
um uh nominees um it was 2017. i wanna
make sure i get that uh
that uh date right right yeah 2017 when
she was confirmed in the seventh circuit
and um she went through incredibly
lengthy hearings yeah for a very
i'm about to be redundant incredibly
lengthy hearings for a very
long period of time it was crazy they
were lengthy it was
take what you would normally think is an
average duration
and it was more than that
hugely more but lengthy public hearing
so this stuff has already been done and
we'll get to the only arguments they
have
left for those who are mug club members
which are actually hysterical
i didn't know that adopting black
children made one a racist
it really does it's a colonizer
you should not do it i know you've been
thinking about it don't do it it's a bad
thing
and then the only other the only i don't
know so you are mexican
the only other argument that oliver
really makes again in a 20 minute video
i encourage you watch all of it then
come back and fact check me
tell me if i'm being dishonest it was
really hard to find anything substantial
the only other argument that he makes
is that america has a problem with
deeply undemocratic institutions
there is a whole system underneath them
that has enabled them to do what they
have done and that brings us
to the second major factor that got us
to where we are now the
deeply undemocratic nature of america's
institutions
and that has led some to suggest taking
the more dramatic step
of expanding the supreme court by adding
justices there are some other steps we
could take
that should be impossible to argue with
at this point steps that would make both
the senate and white house
more representative of the electorate on
the senate side
you could grant statehood to washington
dc and if voters they want it
puerto rico we have to get rid of the
electoral college which might sound
radical
but it really isn't it's not even a new
idea
no court packing adding puerto rico and
abolishing the electoral college sounds
like the potter
the pottery pottery
this is absolutely when people say oh
hold on a second when you talk
there's there's common ground where are
you going to find common ground with a
guy
who believes that we need to abolish the
electoral college pack the supreme court
and fundamentally ch he hasn't watched
schoolhouse rock he doesn't understand
the three branches of government
what are the three branches can everyone
name them executive
judiciary
what do you say i don't know
but the point is the presidency and the
right the house the senate these are
meant to be more fluid that's why they
change
they haven't been very fluid because the
senate majority has been expanded for i
believe the last three midterms and
that's why she's going to be confirmed
you
dip poops so got him i'm trying to clean
him yeah it's a belly kid
it's about as sharp as his points i
think i can boil down his supreme court
nomination
argument uh we want we don't like the
people that you're putting on the court
right so we're just going to add enough
people into
our opinion because well hold on but
then it goes back well okay well then
let's play by those rules well we don't
like what you've done so we'll just keep
we're going to have 700 people in the
supreme court at some point because
they're just going to keep adding until
you get the majority you want and just
because it's not a new idea doesn't mean
it's a good idea
yeah right exactly old ideas that are
very big this has not been hanging
around for a while mainstream and the
republican party at all when you talk
about people who want to erode trust in
institutions
do you realize that if let's assume
libraries were still around they're not
because you know they still use
bing but if you could go to a library
let's say for some reason some nuclear
holocaust all of your iphones or they
just got infected from all the
pornography that 16 year olds are
watching now it's just
very disheartening so you could go to a
library and say hey i want to check
american history
yeah i'd say oh okay yeah i would like
to know about the democratic party
in the 21st century um and the
filibuster
was it the democrats who were pro or
anti-filibuster um hold on a second
um depend which year
no wait i'm sorry which quarter yeah
we're against it we're for it we're
against no mainstream republican
movement has included
court packing no as long as i have been
around
this this this is what happens right now
the same with the electoral college now
they're kind of becoming
uh one note and that they just want to
do away with it but they don't
understand the fundamental roles of
government
you elect a president every four years
or re-elect the president
you have elections on senates and
members of the on the senators and
members of the house
um the court is a permanent position
yeah
that's some of the people it's not meant
to change because it's meant to be a
check
against fluid other forms of government
that is also why
this isn't hard to understand i don't
know why republicans have been making
the wrong argument where they're talking
where they're talking about it well it's
different because in election year and
america
okay no no look this is really simple
okay did barack obama nominate a supreme
court justice
yes yes merrick garland did the senate
confirm it no it was a republican senate
okay
did donald trump nominate a supreme
court justice yes
can the senate confirm it yes republican
senate it's that simple
they both have authority obama uses
authority to nominate the senate uses
authority
to reject donald trump is using his
authority to nominate the senate
is going to use their authority to make
your life a living hell
right and the people have already spoken
on this that's the argument being used
right now that people need to have the
voice in this they did
in 2016 they voted for a president in
2018 they kept the majority of the
senate in his party
right and that was supposed to be four
years and that was supposed to be for
them that two-year period until we have
another election right they've already
spoken it's like getting
it's like getting halfway there and
going well we don't like what you said
previously
we want to wait and see if you change
your mind in the future and joe biden
said something about like that we have
to do this
we have to wait to appoint somebody so
that we can preserve the democracy but
the supreme court is not
it's not a democratic institution well
he also said
this never happened before in the
history of our country that's true not
true
it happened every time oh yeah oh well
which time
all of them you can go back 180 years
right rip van winkle why don't you tell
me
including in your term as vice president
you [ __ ]
yeah this wasn't that long ago ah that's
not something i've ever heard of
we know we know that joe yeah it's
happened
every time but it hasn't always been
confirmed
especially when it's a split government
when it's not a split government
oh okay it happens it's everything when
people try and all of a sudden act like
they are legal i'm not a legal scholar i
can just go through the oh okay
has there had did a president nominate
justice yeah okay was it confirmed oh no
almost all the times yeah that's that's
exactly what i did when this happened i
was like oh that
okay that's a valid argument let's see
if that's true i should collect another
six-figure paycheck from oliver or cnn
because i can do the fact checking that
they refused to do you could be their
entire department but then i'd have to
pay taxes as a business owner
i leave the bill to you and they
wouldn't be able to do their shows
anymore they wouldn't be able to do
their shows
can we fact check how many times donald
trump's straight stealth are speaking
how many times use the word ballot sure
yeah i can use it but i'll
give you some context no no no no no no
please no i'm good
i'm good what are you doing an
impression of xena no no no no
is that a gay zina straight
there is no strike xena confused by your
war cry mr stelter
it really is like it's just remarkable
to me that this is what i don't want to
say you know what i don't know why i'm
saying that it's not remarkable
it's not remarkable at all it is
entirely par for the course it is
and everything i mean look if you can
convince yourself that trump is a threat
to democracy then of course you're going
to believe every conspiracy theory about
how he is going to stay in office until
he's 7 500 years old like joe biden
right
you can make yourself believe that
everything is a threat he's not going to
leave office peacefully and that
his taxes the only reason you know what
they're saying yeah they're saying that
431 million dollars are coming due in
the next four years and that's going to
leave him open to foreign powers
being able to dictate what he does plus
if you want to have a child he makes you
spin yarn into gold
they uh have uh
[Laughter]
donald trump right now like tax info
raises questions let's bring this up on
cnn really quickly
do you have the audio there
questions about whether foreign broke
the law property still haven't seen a
story about
hunter biden receiving millions from the
mosque mayors
what is the word on them using them for
sex slaves i'll tell you what listen
that wouldn't show up on his return
maybe donald trump you don't know he
wrote it all yeah i thought a sex slave
was a write-off
for personal wellness work is stressful
it's stress relief
walking right off my gym membership i
can't i can run off a haircut i appear
on air i can't write off a sex slave or
two
prude think about this for a second
like has donald trump broken listen
there may be loopholes you can audit a
ham sandwich and you can find something
wrong
right this is an issue and donald trump
is being audited right now and that's
why he said that he hasn't released his
tax returns and it doesn't mean that
there's a law about that but it would be
imprudent i'm sure your lawyer would say
don't release a tax return to the public
until your audit is done however
we do have we had proof of hunter biden
with burisma getting this money
getting this influential position in an
energy company for which he had no
qualifications because his father abused
his position of power
and then we have him getting money
directly from the mayor of moscow's
wife and using it for sex slaves
where's the chiron cnn yeah can you give
me a lower third
give me a lower eighth that just reads
hunter biden sex slaves and i understand
you'll say
well the amount is insignificant but we
don't really know the amount
was it the entire 3.5 million we just
took it like you know like a gift card
to dave and busters and he was just a
sex slave heaven
with appetizers and prostitutes i have
no idea
but that's because you're not doing your
job no that's why we don't know and
i would also say that listen uh even if
the unpaid amount in taxes because
someone was using a loophole or for
example maybe basing their primary
residence in florida as opposed to new
york despite the fact that they spent
like six months and two days in new york
city
i would still say that the most
egregious sins
on that tax evasion is not as bad
um as any dollars that go to underage
sex slaves
right i would say one dollar to sex
slaves is one dollar
but that's just me i'm not afraid to
take a risky right position
i'll you know what i'll put myself out
there i know you know what i know this
isn't going to be popular
i don't know everyone's going to agree
with this yeah but i'm anti-uh
uh unsolicited sex slaves are you auntie
uh being able to write it off
as well i am anti uh uh sex traffic
rings with six slaves
i just i know i know this is wild close
the loop i know i know
that it's not popular okay i know that
not everyone's gonna be cool with it but
it's okay that's just me man i thrive on
confrontation
i am anti-sex slave and that is why
i have uh an issue with the biden so uh
we are going to go to speaking of uh
non speaking of non-sex slave scandal
written politicians
which really it's let's be if you have
like a ven diagram
okay you have non-sex slave riddle
politicians
and really it's just another circle of
the bidens and that's 100 percent
so it's just separate circles at that
point okay
barney frank i'm not exactly sure what
the basement i think was more sex slave
role playing
so uh the point is for not let's we're
going to talk about another non-sex
slave guard politician with amy coney
barrett
who might actually be our next supreme
court justice and we'll be reading your
chats
youtube we you know what i'm through
again might not be popular i'm not a
huge fan
of youtube piss off